hi everybody we're going to get underway
the really important mission of today is
to get rid of those robes that you're
wearing which are distinctly
unfashionable and kind of embarrassing
and it's very very strange for those of
us who have been your teachers to see
you in this uniform because we spend the
whole time talking to you about the fact
that this is a sort of anti uniform
school that you're all like experimental
and you're transforming the norms and he
are wearing this sort of pale blue which
is not a color you would ever choose for
any of your projects and all you can see
is your face which now looks
surprisingly clean and lively and so
happy and of course that means your
parents are finally figuring out that
you're in good shape but this is a sort
of a strange strange moment of course
it's a moment of being on a threshold
and because your post professional
students it's a very strange threshold
like you kind of walk in you play with
us for a while and then you rock it out
and in theory you leave faster than you
came in in other words what goes on
during your time with us as you
accelerate but i think it's just very
very important to get rid of those
clothes because also what comes with the
uniform is that everything is sealed up
like all the differences between you get
sealed up but also the openings it goes
full length you basically become a
little bit invisible and this is a
school as you know totally devoted to
opening up architecture to new potential
so it's really about taking away one set
of clothes and trying alternative
operations and that of course as you
know is what I think an architect is
since what an urban designer is is
simply somebody who creates new
potentials which does not mean that you
change the physical fabric of the world
it means much bigger thing which is you
change the way people see the world and
all you do is invite them to think
differently and you've got all sorts of
tricks all sorts of ways to make people
see the world differently and as you
know I think for me this is almost like
a technical procedure
everybody's busy living their lives like
billions of people in in a huge world
and almost everybody is actually trying
to survive I mean it's really a planet
of people trying to survive and what the
architect of the urban designer does is
insert into the rhythms of everyday life
something slightly different kind of a
hesitation a way of thinking different
and it's almost a surgical thing it's
not like you design whole new cities
it's that you change the way people
think about what a city might be what
that means is that you are incredibly
optimistic like an amazingly optimistic
that you will go out in the world make a
little adjustment that will have people
think differently see the world
differently and then maybe live their
lives differently and I think this
optimism is incredibly important if you
read the newspapers what newspapers are
left in a way it's hard not to feel an
incredible sense of sadness about the
way the world is going and what's weird
about an architecture school is
precisely because the world needs our
care we have this extraordinary optimism
when everybody else is sort of down
we're sort of up even in the financial
crisis interestingly the architects who
are the first not to get any jobs as a
result of the crisis the kind of
Canaries of the economic world are the
most optimistic and the most interested
in what the new potentials the new
potentials are so basically what goes on
here is that we spend some time with you
totally crazy in this intense laboratory
of experimentation in theory you come
out somehow different but you also leave
the school totally different as well and
this particular class has changed the
school and the school yet doesn't yet
know what that means in other words you
haven't left yet we're still suffering
the shark of the end of year show so
basically the end of the show we
realized what kind of damage you are
doing to our assumptions to our way of
thinking so basically the school is sort
of thinking well what does that mean for
the future of architecture and education
and you're noticing how interesting the
work of your colleagues is
everybody's not sure what that means in
other words this is an incredibly
exciting moment because we genuinely
don't know what would be the
consequences of this amazing work that's
on display all around the school and in
most situations in most schools and most
commissions in most social situations
you can more or less guess which way
things are going and what's interesting
is you fly into the school at incredibly
high speed it's very hard to get into
the school so you have to go really fast
and be going at such a speed that we
have to admit you but then you when you
leave we don't have their feeling for
where you're going to go precisely
because your mind is so so open so I'm
sort of thrilled to be able to say I
sort of have no idea what this
graduating class is going to do where
they're going to do it and how they're
going to do it all I know is the world
had better be very very careful because
this is a this is an extraordinary class
I would say you are a dangerous class
anybody that hires you does so at great
risk that's why they will hire you
because without taking such a risk
without hiring somebody that will
challenge you you will not you will end
up only with an office that reproduces
your own way of thinking in other words
the reason that you will be hired is
precisely because nobody knows what you
really represent this seems like a very
odd thing to be saying to graduating
students that were incredibly proud that
we don't know what you're going to do
how you're going to do it and the people
that hire you won't know either but that
is the history of this school for its
125 years it has generated new forms of
intelligence and basically the world is
desperately in need of intelligence it's
not in need of people who can build
cities and make cities in fact the world
is exploding more than half the
population of the world is living in
cities there's a vast production of
cities cities are probably the fastest
growing product are on the planet and
therefore in a certain sense the last
thing the world's needs is people who
add can add more buildings to the world
but what the world desperately needs is
a kind of intelligence about this about
what it means and I think you really do
represent a new form of intelligence now
we have tormented you using every
technique
no many many many of the procedures
which are now considered to be quite
acceptable by governments we go way
beyond that way beyond that very few of
the procedures that go on inside a
school of architecture would survive at
general human rights tests you don't eat
you don't sleep you don't have any space
you don't have any food you don't have
any future you have you're basically
suspended in the most radical experiment
of your life and in that space in which
you you you are just treasuring one
thing which is the possible better
future for our society this is one of
the best nuclear reactors in the world
for thinking about the new potentials
for society we did our best to torment
you we really worked hard to make your
life a horror you took revenge with the
end of year show we simply don't know
how to absorb the new form of
intelligence that you have produced
you're transforming the field what I'm
saying to you and I apologize for the
kind of military metaphor but you really
like a heat-seeking missile very
dangerous very fast very intelligent
never know quite what's going on the
world had better watch out the great
secret of course of Columbia has got
nothing to do with the faculty there's
actually no no one relationship between
a spectacular faculty and spectacular
students you can have actually half as
spectacular faculty and it will be the
same the real secret of the school is
the students right there unbelievably
thirsty of course you're interesting
because your post professional so you
have a kind of explosive mix of
real-world experience and expertise and
the experimental work in our laboratory
so you combine the most visionary most
radical thinking about the possible
future with a kind of realism in other
words you are from the world end of the
world and of a lot of the world from
like 65 countries right so this is an
incredibly explosive mix your high
energy incredibly responsible i would
say
respectful of the complexity and also
the fact that so much of our world is
almost unknowable to us in the speed at
which it changes your artists for sure
for sure you could be simply graduating
as artists and I think you would totally
deserve a degree in that I can't tell
you how proud the school is of this
particular year it's like we're
irritatingly proud of what you've done
we consider it a kind of a privilege to
have work with you and this is a genuine
feeling on the part of the of the
students the problem with the post
professional degrees is you hit us so
hard and so quick and the damage is done
and before we know what you've done to
us you've gone so this is my last chance
to sort of thank you for abusing us so
thoroughly and so well I think at some
other level since I'm a historian I
believe at some point the history will
have to be written of your generation I
think that's not a cliche I think
there's two too many new techniques have
been developed in this generation to
such a new combination of skills so at
some point people will look back and say
the meaning of this particular
generation is whatever and whatever
whatever for now all I can say is
unbelievable unbelievable talent and
thirst and for those of you who are from
have been for many many years your
victims your parents and your family we
took over that role for a while we're
very happily hand you back to your
families really shaken and terribly
terribly proud so I just want to
congratulate you you're an amazing class
and they'll never be a way in which your
teachers can fully express to you the
magic connection that was established
for just in the course of only one year
but i can tell you weirdly enough that
both the teachers and students about
20-25 years from now we'll start telling
stories about what went on during your
time here many of the stories will not
be true actually but what will happen is
there'll be a sense that something went
on because I'm sure in the same way that
I don't know what you really did when
you were with us I'm sure you don't know
either and we need to meet again like
five years from now 10 years from now 15
years from now and try to figure out
what it is that you've done the reason I
think and this is I'm repeating myself
but I just want to say it again the
reason the teachers are so amazed by
this particular post professional year
is you simply have defeated our ability
to generate a kind of cliche description
of what it is that your generation
represents that's an amazing achievement
because you have a faculty that are
literally some of the world's experts in
generating cliche descriptions of what's
going on in our field basically if you
can defeat your faculty in in terms of
describing what they're doing there's
nobody in the world that will be able to
contain you and it's this inability to
continue that makes you so dangerous so
beautiful and so amazing so again just
saying to you from the faculty
unbelievable i hope you every now and
then let us know what you're up to and
again i want to tell you i bet you you
don't know what's going to happen we
don't know but within a couple of years
the damage will be done the world had
better be warned anyway congratulations
a great class
you know it's like a science fiction
movie you're like a new technology and
we're scurrying around where humans
you're not and we we're trying to figure
you out we're trying to figure out are
you kind will you treat us well we know
the world will change now that you're in
charge right we know it we just don't
know what that means so we're going to
start going through the program's
beginning was the master of science in
advanced architectural design and the
director of that program was super Lee
amazing in Ricky Walker not I used to
describe him as the candidate for nicest
person in the universe but basically
when the other candidates for the
position met him they gave up he just
sort of sweded them out and what's
amazing force about Enrique is this
sweetness and this tenderness is
combined with what might be one of the
very sharpest minds in our field so how
can sweetness and sharpness be in one
person how could it be in a whole year
how could it be the sharpest fastest
most experimental year and yet be
incredibly tender about a world that
needs our care so in every way Enrique
represents the school in the best
possible spirit Enrique
a guitar
thank you Bob Christina a case Carlo
Charlie Alice rocky Jana Olivo
jose antonio aragua
michael steven are they honest the
second
Danya oughtta
alexandros abalone tease
blum suck bang
for hundreds bargain
hernan betanzos
Adam Bentley billard
Barrett William Brown Benjamin Simon car
gonzalo Emilio Casillas
alejandro de castro matar good one
Chang
Rika Chaudhary
anastacio holy
sang yong chun
dahveed ricardo de la vida Ricardo
davila araki de l'ile de metrio glue
tsukuyomi say fetch oh kudi da z
Bradley no goes one
Diego Fernandez Villaverde sergio gomez
davido's Waldo Gonzalez
Stephanie a hook
genichiro horikawa
seung hyun joong
a vaguely acara Holly oh
and Kim
moon Yong Kim
kozara bullions each way you like
Patrick steven liao's L they woke Lee
see you
marilla's lil over
jae hyung Lim Annie kar ke lo
John Henry lock
matthew james lots
Gwendolyn Christine mcFarland
neither Madhu
o Allah Marquez to borrow
Eduardo morale Gonzalez
annamaria terrace meister cinemas doggie
Karen bahar AA meeting Jurgis Metro
Jurgis misaki Mourinho boo kuna Adolfo
Nadal
saskia marina na ghal
marcelo Javier najera Garcia Gabriel
casaya Nichols a flat knees on
that 80 Nevada
Zachary Coleman all Zach
james patrick O'Meara
Joshua Harrison Padgett
eleni pop Anastasio
san juan park ssangyong park sana Raju
bhai Patel Pablo Perez Palacios eleni
petal OT Megan Ruth win Michael Casey
rim
natalia rumeli OT a marathi solace
Ignacio Sandra
Georgie Andre serpa Guillermo civilian
Oh Jaya to sha Zhi Zhu Shi
hero masta shibata sangwon shin James
boys Sykes a drew the norm smith
a man will stay bracha keys
in her soul
Coco takahashi
jennifer jo is factotum get through
todeschini jaws robert vela Eric
jean-pierre Danya Heath Brandon West
Chichen young
current weenie young Andrew Murray
Zaleski adriana la cerva yo Lauren
Heather zuker
so this is the aad class of 2009
you
okay so we're going to do the Master of
Science in architecture and urban design
a totally amazing program if you listen
to the urban designers they think that
everything else in the school actually
belongs to them and precisely because
the urban design has this ability to
bring together all aspects of the built
environment it's a program that's going
from strength to strength because as you
know from a bomber on urban designers
what we need this is the class the
director of the program is is Professor
Richard plants who's been an absolutely
a genius i would say in guiding steadily
this program towards the future that it
needs in other words at the moment in
which there is this call for urban
design on a global scale there is a
program ready to deliver the kind of
intelligence that's necessary this has
been years and years that the school has
been making itself ready for this moment
this mission and it's Richards credit
that this has happened Richard
okay on with the let's get on with it
haha okay okay Benjamin Fitzgerald Abba
man
Oh habiba act akhtar Maria Alicia the
doc Mariela Victoria Casanova marianela
Castillon Olympia chair mozzie we don't
Robert Matthew Drury Jamison Neil
fallado Luella Gallagher shruti via
kamar blanca y luis Kelly a marta guerra
pastry on donna marie portland-area en
jou en suisse win CA AKA cancel Zhang
GUI Zi Jing rahmah newark and Annie dong
say Kim Martha Cole atrani amardeep
Levana Hector Lewis limb
shreya mallu Danielle Montez Santa Maria
Vivian teen wing ngong one hung oh
margarita papadimitriou Yakima Emilio
Pena Perez oh wait I'm out of order here
where are we yes Ginny sharma Shane we
she
Julia Melanie siedler Ashley rose
Spatafore de Aquila sreen bus okay
here's aquila Manya Tashia tire william
christopher taped j Tintin Emily Miriam
widen off wazoo
nita kuva Boone chu Zhang Ying Ning
zhang and taher Zoya
so this is the class of aud 2009
we had a request from the students to
have no prizes this year due to a sort
of deep sense of egalitarian democratic
unity but we've decided to go against
the students wishes and award prizes
anyway it's really hard toward these
surprises the student student should
know that the faculty spends an entire
day looking at every single drawing of
the portfolio and arguing and arguing
and arguing so the end result is the
selection of people to win prizes that
somehow represent the class not just the
person but represent the spirit of the
of the whole class was very very
difficult to do this year because the
there was really incredibly beautiful
work being done so we're going to begin
with the William Kinney fellows memorial
traveling prizes a series of different
committees the first one is from the aad
program the advanced architectural
design program and the winner for this
one this year for a project entitled the
element of the street in lina bo buddies
work examining the case of the of the
theater and restorations plans for
Salvador Bahia is eleanii petal et
and for a project entitled finding a
balance between vernacular architecture
and developing building practices in
Bhutan Megan Quinn
for a project entitled the Babel and the
pioneer manual of Buenos Aires an
interview with Clarinda testa malicious
lil over
and the final award from the advanced
architectural design subcommittee is for
project entitled interstate topology
Matthew lads
and from the architecture and urban
design subcommittee for a project
entitled learning from Japan the role of
rail infrastructure and urban growth
dongs away Kim and Daniel Montes Santa
Maria
for project entitled learning from green
hat ? reevaluate greenwash issues Koosh
inquiry and sheng why she
okay the gloves are off school wide
Kenny Awards infrastructure as an
economic and instrument lessons from
Japanese stimulus spending during the
last decade Benjamin everman
for project entitled Frank Lloyd Wright
meets Japan Diego Fernandez Villaverde
and for project called the role of the
mall in the process of spatial
reconciliation in South Africa Anna
Maria Meister and Andrea sell whiskey
I think if you listen to the sound of
these research projects you understand
what I mean about not knowing the way
the world is going this is an
extraordinarily complex set of questions
here's one fast cheap and out of control
without architects or why infrastructure
will not save us John Locke
figure this one out 800 meters of
high-density Vivian yo
a project entitled post-soviet oaken
urban ography analysis of hyper growing
and shrinking cities in Kazakhstan Julia
sheitel and younger
and now for the Lucille Schmeiser low
and fish memorial prizes this is each
studio critic chooses one person from
their studio who most represents the the
best design work addressing the problem
in their last year of work here which is
open to a Mac students to aad students
into UD students and of course now we're
going to do first the AED students so
Mario Gordon's studio on the posthuman
from the critical theory Institute
University of Chicago I sorry of
california-irvine the winner of the lone
fish was Andrea sell whiskey
it's kind of impossible to win these
prices you know hawaiian herreros chose
for his project interventions and blocks
of the central city which was in madrid
her horn Cristobal I'm in Turkey
see some people get the point right away
okay Jeffrey and arbors amazing studio
project entitled things will get worse
before they get better was a double
award to Bradley angles men and young
adults
Jeffrey Johnson's project on mega Blok
Beijing China double award to Guillermo
Saviano and and Ignacio Sarah
aight Kellis studio had the title speed
territory communication and the fastest
most territorial communicator was John
Locke
giuseppe el enano an audit ola low-tech
their project the monograph studio went
to elaine a paparazzo
so it Enrique Walker completing I think
the series of this most amazing studio
is called the dictionary of received
ideas has defeated us by going for a
quartet which I will be impossible for
me to say with any accuracy here we go
soon kwan-yuen key kyon na sang Kwan
park and Jennifer Joyce factor town
ok
now to the architecture and urban design
low and fish awards are the teachers
which as you probably know the the
students work collaboratively on a
project with collaborative teachers so
the collaborative teaching team of
Richard plants Michael Conrad petrochem
Kate off Geeta Mehta and Eric Prodi as a
visiting critic had a studio entitled
Vienna esperan emerging social
agglomeration of place and there were
four winners matter Guerra
Vivian yo
Emily widen half
and knows who
for the studio entitled Mumbai moving up
dharavi Richard plants Michael Conrad
petrochem Kate off and Geeta meta
awarded to four people the first of
which is been a Berman
and then re all right
Hector limb
and finally Julia Seidel
okay now we have a set of honor awards
for excellence in design which is in
recognition of the high quality of work
and the design students using the
students program of studies this is what
they would not stop fighting about four
hours and when they finally came up with
this list everybody agreed this was the
hot list so the hot people are number
one Jose Uruguay's
jamieson fajardo
misaki marino bow
said no bahara
Joshua Padgett
Ignacio Sandra
Emily riding off
andrea is Ella whiskey
this year the faculty invented a new
award because there is hot and then
there is very hot and very hard on a
reward with distinction for Bradley
engelsman
and now for the G set prize for
excellence in urban design which is to
recognize the student whose work in the
urban design program has been simply the
most outstanding and there was no doubt
it was Vivian no
so there's hot and then there's very
hard and then there's untouchable hard
and that's the William where prize and
the soul Kaplan traveling fellowship to
recognize the student in the advanced
architectural design program whose work
throughout the studio's has been simply
outstanding which was funded by a
bequest from saw Kaplan who graduated
from the school in 1957 and the prize is
for travel and study following
graduation this is the highest honor and
this is for John Locke
so this is an amazing group of people
you could hear it if you hear what
they're thinking about you hear what
they're doing you see what they're doing
this is a shockingly good class this is
the class of 2009
fune that way